what I am most appreciative about my
husband he does all the stuff that I'm
bad at and I don't want to do I really
do think it's a 50/50 partnership my
husband he is my best but no I love that
he involves them and things that he
loves like sports and working out he
supports all my crazy ideas I was a
single mother when I met him and he has
taken my oldest son and has been a
father to him I think that the longer
were married the longer we do the
parenting gig together the more we
appreciate each other he picks him up
I'll drop him off he's the coach of the
soccer team
he hates the term that he's watching our
daughter he's like no I'm being a father
he's really understanding that it is
work being a parent like he's so good
about not leaving me to just do
everything I'm kind of like this monster
ball of stress who can't deal with like
any of the kids and you know I can't
have all three of yelling at me at one
time and he's just like I got this it's
fine he is present when he's home most
important is trying to raise confident
kids